Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Beslenmeyi doymak,
doymayı damak zevkinize uygun gıdalarla
karnı doldurmak mı sanıyorsunuz?
"Ben peynirsiz kahvaltı yapamam."
"Ne kadar peynir tüketirsem
o kadar güçlü olacağım."
"Ne kadar et tüketirsem
"Düzenli yemek yemeliyim," gibi
"Yemekten sonra meyve
yemeliyim," gibi bilgilerin
doğruluğuna ne kadar inanıyorsunuz?
Ne kadar biliyorsunuz,
ki bu gerçek bir bilgidir.
İki yıl kimya fakültesinde
organik kimyayı gördüm.
Altı yıl tıp fakültesi, dört yıl ihtisas,
üstüne 60 bin sayfa bilimsel
beslenme dökümanı taradım.
Bu bilgilerin doğruluğunu bulamadım.
Sağlıklı, tıbbi beslenme
bu klişeleşmiş cümlelerin
çok ötesinde bir şeymiş:
Hücre düzeyinde bir beslenme.
Hücrenin kendisini anlamadan
beslenmeyi anlamak mümkün
değil, diye anladım.
Hücrenin zarına bakın;
en küçük birimi,
en basit birimi, güvenlik duvarı.
Bir güvenlik duvarı düşünün ki,
3 bin giriş çıkış kapısı var.
bu iki tabaka omega 3 yağından oluşmuş
ve bu yağlar sizin sofranızdan
gelmiş oraya yerleşmiş.
Bu kapıların açılması,
bu omega 3 yağlarının çok narin
bir hareketiyle gerçekleşmekte.
Basamak basamak baktığınızda
hücre zarından aldınız omega 3 yağını,
gördünüz bacaklarının nasıl açıldığını.
Bu bacaklar acaba fonksiyonel olmazsa
acaba şu görevi yapabilir mi?
Kapının açılabilmesi için bu
bacakların esnek olması gerekir.
Bu bacaklar sertleşirse, kasılırsa
işini ne kadar düzgün yapabilir?
Belki kapı bir açılacak,
daha kapanamayacak,
herkes girip çıkabilecek.
Belki de açılması gereken
vakitte cevap veremeyecek.
Çok yaygın bildiğiniz bir insülin
direnci diye bir kavram var.
Bu hastalığı çoğu zaman duyarsınız;
insülin gelir, kapıyı çalar,
şekere "Buyur kapıyı aç," der.
Kapının açılması gereken o süreç
buradaki bacağı kırık bir omega 3
yağı yüzünden gerçekleşemez
ve insülin bir başka kapıyı zorlar.
Nasıl olsa kapı çok, 3 bin tane kapı!
Bu kapılardan bir başkası,
bir başkasını zorlarken
insülin, olması gereken dozun
dört misli, beş misli miktarda
üretilmek zorunda kalır.
Bir pankreasın bu kadar yüksek
miktarda üretime dayanabilmesi
10 yıl, 15 yıl mümkün olur.
Daha sonra, "Artık ben de dayanamam!" der
ve siz diyabet denen bu hastalığın
yolculuğuna başlamış olursunuz.
Yani bir diyabet tanısının geçmişi
10 yıl, 15 yıl öncesinden gelmiştir
ama asıl konu burada insüline
bir cevapsızlık vardır.
Bu cevapsızlığın sebebi
sofralarımızda mı gerçekleşiyor acaba?
Bakın arkadaşlar,
trans yağ denince
"Ben çocuğuma trans yağ
yedirmem!" diyor anne.
"Evime, mutfağıma
trans yağ sokmam!" diyor.
"Trans yağ içeren cipsler almam!" diyor
ama trans yağı kendi evde yapıyor.
Mutfağı bir trans yağ
fabrikası olmuş, haberi yok.
Trans yağla cis yağ arasında,
yani sağlıklı bir yağla sağlıksız
bir yağ arasında çok mu fark var?
Bakın arkadaşlar, hiçbir fark yok,
sadece basit bir bacağın kırılmasıdır.
Tamamen izomerdir,
aynıdır, aynı formüldür,
sadece bir bacak kırılmasıdır.
Bir açı değişmesidir.
Bir yağı faydalılıktan zararlı
bir yağa çevirmek bu kadar basit!
Nasıl mı gerçekleşiyor?
Buyurun, benim annem,
benim Ayşe teyzem
mutfağında her gün yapıyor bunu.
Organik kimya bize şunu öğretiyor:
Her yağın belirli ısılarda
açılarını değiştirir,
belirli ısılarda bacaklarını kırarsınız.
O kırık bacaklı yemekleri
yaparsınız da haberiniz olmaz.
Bu kimya bilgisi bize diyor ki,
aslında biz bunu çok sık yapıyoruz.
Simit yiyoruz,
simidin üzerindeki susamın ne kadar
değerli yağlar içerdiğini araştırsanız
sayfalar dolusu bilgi çıkar karşınıza
ama hepsi transta.
Çünkü yüksek ısı, 200 derecelik ısı
organik kimya der ki, bu transa geçmiştir.
Moleküler zincir yapısı bozuktur.
Transa geçmiş olması demek,
onun elinden omega 3 yağı olma,
omega 6 yağı olma özelliğini almaz,
hâlen omega 3 yağıdır.
O sadece görevini yapamayacak
durumdadır, bacağı kırıktır!
Yani değerlidir ama yararlıdır, iş görmez.
Hücre zarının o harika
geçişi gerçekleşemez.
1/10 saniye gibi bir zaman diliminde
kalsiyumun geçtiği bir yerden
magnezyum geçemiyor,
potasyumun girdiği hiçbir
yerden sodyum geçemiyor.
Herkes kendi kapısını biliyor,
böyle hassas bir yerde
bu görevini yapamıyor.
Bacakları kırık!
Yumurta pişiriyoruz,
en değerli omega 3 yağını
bulabileceğiniz bir yer.
Bu yağ orada dakikalarca
kaynadıktan sonra kapkara olmuş,
bütün omega 3 yapıları deforme olmuş hâlde
ama sağlıklı diye yiyoruz ama transta.
Bakıyorsunuz Ayşe teyzem
bir soğan kavuracak,
sanki yedi mahalle ötedeki
komşusuna haber vermek istiyor!
Bütün kokuyu yayıyor bütün memlekete.
O soğanın o hâliyle,
etrafa yaydığı o kokularla,
aslında kullandığı yağı transa geçiriyor.
Bana diyor ki, "Ben zeytinyağı
kullanıyorum doktor bey."
Zeytinyağı da transa geçiyor.
Tereyağı kullanıyor,
tereyağı da transa geçiyor.
Pirinç pilavı pişirecek, arpa
şehriyesini bir kavuruyor önce.
Kapkara etmiş bir arpa,
kendisine hayrı kalmamış,
bütün yağı da okside etmiş transta,
bununla çocuğunu beslediğini zannediyor.
Biz "En harika şifa!" diye
bağırdığımız çörek otuna bakın.
Çörek otu çörek otu olalı
ömrü hayatında bu kadar itibar kaybetmedi.
Ayşe teyzenin böreğinin süsüne dönüşmüş,
sadece süs malzemesi.
O kadarcık süs malzemesini bile
verivermiş fırına 200 derecede, transta!
Bununla beslendiğini zannediyor.
Allahtan ki Ayşe teyzenin gücü
dünyanın 27 derecelik açısını
değiştirmeye yetmiyor.
Bir açı değişimi
basit bir hadise değildir.
Bütün fonksiyonunu değiştiriyor.
27 derecelik bir açı değişimi
mevsimleri oluşturuyor;
bu mevsimlerle,
biz yeryüzünün hayatın devamını
gerçekleştiriyor olduğunu biliyoruz.
Demek ki küçük bir değişim değildir bu.
Soruyorum, imkân dahilinde olsaydı da,
bir grup insana:
"Sizi öyle bir besleyeceğiz ki
tamamen trans yağlarla besleneceksiniz
ve tamamen ölü besinlerle besleneceksiniz.
Ne zaman hasta olacağınızı
merak ediyoruz."
Kim buna evet derdi?
Hiç kimse!
Ama böyle kocaman bir gemide,
1945 yılında bir olay yaşanıyor.
2 bin kişilik bir mürettebat 6 ay boyunca,
aslında görev 1 yıl,
6 ay sonra 111 tane askeri ölüyor.
O zamanki tıp bilgisi bize skorbit dedi
ama bugünkü organik
kimya farklı bir şey gördü.
O gemide canlı gıda yoktu.
O gemide her şey ölü grubundaydı.
Her şey konserveydi ama her şey de vardı.
Bu gemide "canlı gıda" yoktu.
"Canlı" gıda yoktu.
Canlı ne?
Ölü ne?
Gıdanın canlılığı mı olur!
O gemide taze sebze yoktu
çünkü çabuk çürüyecekti,
gemiye alınmamıştı.
O gemide kavrulmamış çerez yoktu,
o gemide taze et yoktu.
Hatta taze su bile yoktu.
O gemide bu ölümlerin sebebi neydi?
Canlı ve ölüyü birbirinden
ayırabilmek mümkün mü?
Bugün ORP denilen bir cihaz ile
organik kimya, bize bunun
mümkün olduğunu öğretti.
Oxidation Reduction Potential,
oksidasyon redüktife edebilme gücü.
Yani yaşlanmayı durdurabilme gücü,
yani paslanmayı durdurucu güç.
Bir gıdanın böyle bir özelliği var
ama aynı gıda, okside de edebilir
antioksidan da olabilir.
Buna biz karar veriyoruz.
Sofraları düzenlerken
biz bir tercih yapıyoruz.
Bakın bir bademin serüvenine:
Henüz çağla, -230 ORP.
Yani 230 tane çöp temizleme özelliği var.
Bu çöplerin ne olduğunu anlatacağım.
Aynı badem kurudu, -80;
80 tane çöp temizler.
Gece suya koydunuz, canlandı.
Oldu 180, bir anda canlanmaya başladı.
Daha fazla güçlendi
ama bunu kavurdunuz.
+200 tane çöp getirir vücudunuza.
Bu çöplerin nereye gittiğini anlatacağım.
Sonra, "Ya ben öyle bir
kavurmadan lezzet almıyorum.
Çifte kavrulmuş seviyorum," dediniz.
+400 tane, buyurun.
Biz bir aracın motoruyla
insan bedeninin motorunu
bir karşılaştırmak istiyorum.
Araç içindeki bütün pistonun hareketiyle,
mikro çapta metal parçacıkları aşınır.
Bu aynı zamanda aracınızın
motorunun ömrünü belirler
ve bilirsiniz ki, 10 bin-15 bin
kilometrede bir bunu değiştirirseniz
aracınızın ömrü uzar.
Buradaki yapılan şey, yağın yalıtkan --
yağın motora hasar veren ısının
önünde tampon görevi görmesi.
Yağınızı değiştirirsiniz, aracınızın
bakımını sürdürürsünüz.
Peki insan bedeninde
mitokondride neler oluyor?
Bu çarklar gibi dönüyor,
hem de daha muazzam.
Bir saniyede ETS sistemi dediğimiz
Elektron Taşıma Sisteminde
40 reaksiyon gerçekleşiyor
ve her mitokondride gerçekleşiyor.
Bir arabanın motorunda
mikro çapta parçacıklar açığa çıkar da
insan bedeninin mitokondrisinde
hiç mi çöp açığa çıkmaz!
Yeryüzünde hareketliliğin
ve reaksiyonun olduğu
hiçbir yer var mı ki atık çıkmasın!
Evinizde kırdığınız bir yumurta
bile çöpe dönüşmüyor mu,
bir yumurtanın kabuğu çöp olmuyor mu?
Yeryüzünde hayatın olduğu
her yerde çöp de vardır,
bunlar hep birlikte gidecektir.
Bugün bu çöplerin,
aslında hücreler düzeyinde
nasıl temizlendiğini göreceksiniz.
Bir mitokondrinin içerisindeki bu
bütün açığa çıkan elektronlara
biz serbest radikal diyoruz.
Bunlar saldırgandır.
Saldırgan olan serbest radikalleri,
sizler tampone edersiniz.
İşte o bademin -200 olunca
topladığı elektron boyutu
çöpleri böyle toplardı.
Çöp buradan gelir.
Çöp mitokondrinin içindeki
elektronları toplayarak atılır.
Nedir bunu atan,
yediğiniz gıdanın canlılığıdır.
Bunu en yüksek düzeyde
görebileceğiniz gıdalar mor gıdalardır.
Birkaç tanesinin bilgisini
vereceğim fikir olsun diye.
Bir mor şalgamın ORP değeri -800'dür.
Yani 800 tane çöpü toplamaya gücü yeter
ama kavrulmuş bir bademin de +400'dür.
400 tane çöp taşıdınız,
neyi tercih ediyor olduğunuzun
farkında mısınız?
Bir aracın motorunun temizliği
ömrünü belirliyor da
insanın bedeninin temizliği ömrünü
belirlemiyor mu zannediyorsunuz?
İnsanoğlunun ömrü de
yediklerinin oluşturduğu atıkların yaptığı
hasardan başka hiçbir şey değildir.
Yediklerimizin oluşturduğu
hasarlardan başka bir şey değildir
ve maruz kaldığımız radyasyonların,
maruz kaldığımız toksinlerin
toplamıdır insanoğlu.
İşte oksitlenme dediğimiz,
işte saldırı dediğimiz budur.
İnsan bedeninin yediklerinin
oluşturduğu hasarlarsa bu,
sizler de bedeninizde yaşlanmayı
durdurmak mı istiyorsunuz
ya da yavaşlatmak mı istiyorsunuz?
Buyurun size formül:
Yaşlanmak yediklerimizin
oluşturduğu hasar,
genç kalmanın formülü, serbest
radikal üreten gıdaları azaltın
ve temizleyenleri arttırın.
(Alkış)